now in late march the [ __ ] riot
activist lucy stein put on a bright
green food delivery uniform and she
slipped out of her small moscow flat
she'd been under house arrest there for
more than a year as a long-time critic
of the putin regime that she'd
been detained for a protest calling for
opposition leader alexa navalny's
release now her girlfriend and fellow
activists escaped similar charges and
the country and the pair are now
reunited and performing in europe to
raise funds for ukrainian refugees i
spoke to her about her nerve-wracking
journey and a very special travelling
companion
you escaped from moscow in march after
being under house arrest for over a year
can you just explain why you were under
house arrest i were under house arrest
for the criminal case
it was like about
so-called breaking code rules
but actually it was because of the
protest rally
uh we participated to support alexander
wiley who was
[Music]
in prison
after poison he was poisoned um so
it was a
criminal case for
10 people we were sent
under house arrest for
like half of a year
and
after it we were sentenced for
the restriction of freedom it is uh
it's uh also like a house arrest so very
difficult conditions to be living under
and how did you
manage to escape
firstly it was a complete house arrest
when i
wasn't able to leave home any time but
then
it was like
only a restriction for a night
to leave for apartments so i had a
daytime and
i left
house like in the morning and
um
when they
found out that
i'm not
there at my place i already
was too far
and you wore a disguise
i had to wear this
skewed
food delivery costume
and
so when i realized that i have to escape
from russia i
just
used this costume again
and how did you manage to get from
russia to lithuania which is where you
are now
it was it were three cars
first car in russia then second car to
belarus and a third car
to lithuania actually but um
i'm not sure that uh
uh it's a good idea to talk about uh
this um
method a lot because i'm not the last
person who have to
leave russia
this way
yeah that makes a lot of sense and
you're saying you're not the only person
of course who's had to leave russia i
think your girlfriend has also managed
to escape
yeah she did she did the same thing
after me
and so lucy you escaped russia with
somebody who did you escape with
mr rat
said
how did you escape with him
i put him in
my
delivery food back
and
he was staying there
uh during this trip
and how was he during the trip was he
okay
yeah he's uh he's a strong red i i think
he
understood that we have to
leave
our home
and why did you just scarce decide to
make your escape in march was that
because the situation had got more
dangerous after the invasion of
ukraine first of all i realized that um
if i
if before i wanted to
wait for the end of my sentence and
be able to leave russia legally and to
come back to russia legally
i changed my mind
[Music]
after the invasion to ukraine because
i
understood that i
don't want to live there anymore even
if uh
they
would leave me alone
and no
jails no arrests no prosecution
um
even if i
would be a free person in russia i just
don't want to
[Music]
stay there anymore if you're staying
there
or not even there you just can't be
silenced about what's happening and if
you can't um
and if you call
the war the war
it's also forbidden
um
you are
risking like to be imprisoned for 15
years
so if you criticize the war in ukraine
you could go to prison for 15 years now
that's that's a situation
even if you're just calling the war the
war because
our government
calls it
like special operation i think some
people in the west don't understand why
more people in russia aren't protesting
about ukraine or aren't speaking out do
you think that's because people support
the war or because people are too afraid
about what would happen if they did
speak out
if russian people
would
know the truth they won't
support the war but
um
not all of them but
i think a big part
of them are just
watching tv propaganda and
they don't know what's uh actually
happening there and they think that
uh ukrainians are nasties and uh russian
soldiers um
are
peacemakers
it like being brainwashed
yeah yeah brainwashed
yeah
you're 25 years old
you've been under house arrest for a
year
you had to flee your home
these are really big big sacrifices for
someone your age you could have lived a
much much easier life
why did you feel you had to do it
if you live in russia
you have
to watch every
day
what's happening and
you just feel uh bad if you are uh
silenced and uh
it's uh
it's kind of uh it's for for me it's uh
this way um
i just
couldn't
ignore it even then you had to speak out
yeah
and my mom
yelled at me because star staff had
can you wait like
several days
escape and
post anything you want but i
couldn't
and it's even dangerous to like to make
a repost about
um
about war criminal
and
about what happened in bulgaria for
example
thank you so much honestly it's been
great to talk to you we really
appreciate it thank you
thank you